نبدا ملفات هذا اليوم من تطورات حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا اذ شهدت اجواء مقاطعات روسيه
عده بما فيها العاصمه موسكو هجمات
بالمسيرات ورغم ان السلطات الروسيه قالت
انها احبطت معظمها سواء في موسكو ام
روستوف التي زارها الرئيس الروسي يوم امس
فان الوضع في كورسك كان مختلفا لقد اعلنت
وكاله تاس عن تحطم مسيره اوكرانيه على سقف
محطه القطار في مدينه كورسك ما ادى الى
اصابه خمسه اشخاص بالجروح عموما تقع على
بعد نحو 90 كيلومترا عن الحدود مع
اوكرانيا كما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اسقاط مسيره اوكرانيه في ستوبينسكي جنوب
موسكو دون وقوع اضرار او ضحايا واعلنت
الوكاله الروسيه للنقل الجوي عن استئناف
حركه الطيران في مطاري فنوكوفو
في موسكو بعد تعليقها صباح اليوم
من موسكو نرحب بمراسله الجزيره رانيا
دريدي من اوليسا مراسل الجزيره عامر لافي
عامر ان نبدا منك وقصف المسيرات على موسكو
ومحطه قطار كورسك ايضا ويبدو ان
الاوكرانيين يركزون على الهجمات بالمسيرات
في الفتره الماضيه
نعم عثمان بالفعل يعني هذا هو النهج الان
الاوكراني والاساس وفقا لكثير من المحلين
هنا ان اوكرانيا تريد ان تشعر الشعب
الروسي بان ثم حرب تخوضها بلادهم وبالتالي
الهدف نوع من الضغط ربما على الحكومه
الروسيه الاعتبار انه طوال الفتره الماضيه
لم تكن تتاثر المدن الروسيه بهذه الحرب
وكان شيئا لم يكن وكان لا يوجد حرب ولا
يوجد حرب قد تخوضها بلادهم في اتجاه
اوكرانيا وبالتالي واضح ان المسيرات
والمصنعه محليا تعلم ان الامين مجلس الامن
الاوكراني تحدث في اكثر من مناسبه عندما
قال لا يمكن لاحد ان يسالنا عن الاسلحه
التي صنعناها بايدينا اين سنستخدمها على
اعتبار ان هناك نوع من الوعود الاوكرانيه
لحلفائهم الغربيين بعدم استخدام الاسلحه
الغربيه التي يحصلون عليها في داخل
الاراضي الروسيه وبالتالي هذه كلها عباره
عن مسيرات واسلحه مصنعه محليا وبالتالي
كما يقول الاوكرانيين يمكن استخدامها هنا
في داخل الاراضي الروسيه وتحقيق الهدف
الذي تحدثنا عنه بالحديث عن الوضع
الميداني هنا في البحر الاسود تحديدا قبل
قليل الاعلنت قياده عمليات الجنوب بان
هناك في البحر الاسود 9 قطع حربيه
احداها غواصه تحمل اربعه صواريخ من نوع
كروز وقالت المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات
الجنوب بان الوضع مرتفع الخطوره لماذا لان
الغواصه تقصف من داخل البحر من عمق البحر
وبالتالي يصعب على الانذار والرادارات
الاوكرانيه ان تكشف متى سيتم قصف المناطق
هنا في اوديس وما حوله وبالتالي رات
الجميع الى الانتباه والترقب لكن طبعا
تحدثت عن ان هناك خوف يجتاح هذه السفن
التي تتحرك بشكل مستمر بسبب الاستهداف
المستمر من قبل
الزوارق المسيره الاوكرانيه في البحر
الاسود لموضوع ربما اللافت اليوم عثمان
حديث الاوكرانيين عن قرب استلامهم لطائرات
اف 16 تعلم وزير الدفاع الاوكراني تحدث عن
ان الطيارين بداوا بالتدريب على هذه
الطائرات التي يدرك الاوكرانيين ويتحدثون
كثيرا عنها ستغير سير هذه الحرب وقال بانه
هم بحاجه الى سته اشهر لكي يتمكنوا من
استخدام هذه الطائرات ايضا قائد القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه تحدث عن هذا الموضوع
وقال بانه تجهيز المطارات الاوكرانيه تعلم
المطارات الاوكرانيه والنظام الطائرات
المستخدمه في اوكرانيا هي طائرات روسيه
سوفيتيه وبالتالي المدرجات غير مؤهله
لاستخدام الاف 16 قال عندما نستلم طائرات
الاف 16 ستكون مطاراتنا جاهزه ايضا
لاستقبال هذه الطائره التي ستغير سير
المعارك هنا في هذه الحرب انتقل اليك
رانيا ماذا تقول الروايه الروسيه بشان
الهجمات الاوكر انيه بالمسيارات والتي
قالت انه تم اسقاطها
نعم بالفعل يعني اولا اود الاشاره الى ان
مثل هذه الهجمات باتت روتينيه في واقع
الامر وفعليا هذه الهجمات مستمره لاسيمه
على المناطق الحدوديه منذ اكثر من عام
وعليه يمكن القول انه لا جديد حتى هذه
اللحظه في الموضوع فيما يتعلق باستهداف
العاصمه يعني تم اسقاط المسيره في منطقه
نائيه في المناطق الجنوبيه في مقاطعه
رستوف الحدوديه ايضا تم اسقاط ثلاث مسيرات
اما في مقاطعه كورس بالطبع يعني
طالما ان هذه المسايره اصطدمت بسقف محطه
القطارات فتسبب ذلك باندلاع حريق وفي تلك
اللحظه كان هناك خمسين شخصا في المبنى من
الزوار وركاب القطارات وعليه فان خمسه
اشخاص اصيبوا بجروح طفيفه بحسب المعطيات
الرسميه التي صدرت قبل قليل عن الحاكم فان
اثنان من المصابين حتى لم يذهب الى المشفى
فيما تم تقديم المساعده الاوليه على الفور
لثلاثه اخرين قد غادروا الى منازلهم اذا
مساله استهداف المناطق الحدوديه هي مساله
متواصله مستمره امس ايضا كان هناك
الاستهداف للعاصمه موسكو خلال الايام
الماضيه يمكن القول تقريبا هذه الحوادث
باتت مكرره شبه يوميا ولكن يعني نحن نعلم
غنوه ان الجانب الروسي هدد اوكرانيا مرارا
من مغبه الاستمرار بمثل هذه الهجمات
واشارت موسكو لانها تبقي لنفسها الحق
بالرد حاليا انطلاقا يعني مما نسمعه من
قبل وزاره الدفاع يتم التركيز اكثر على
استهداف مواقع تصنيع هذه المسيرات لاسيما
وكانت وزاره الدفاع يعني الروسيه اعلنت عن
استهداء موانع في يعني
الساحليه الاخرى في اوكرانيا تلك التي كان
يتم فيها تصنيع المسيرات لاسيما الزوارق
المسيره اذا روسيا حاليا تركز على استنفاذ
قدرات الجانب الاوكراني فيما يتعلق
بالمسيرات ويعني الاهم بالنسبه لموسكو
الجزئيه ليس يعني ليس ما يتعلق
يعني دوله انشاء هذه المسيرات بل الاهداف
التي يتم
ضربها روسيا تحدثت كثيرا في الاونه
الاخيره ان الغرب يطالع فيما سمته
بالاعمال الارهابيه بالهجمات الارهابيه
حسب تعبير موسكو طالما الجانب الاوكراني
يحدث يحصل على كل الاحداثيات يتم تنسيق كل
الضربات مع حلفائه الغربيين الذين يعملون
على الارض مع المستشارين العسكريين لا
سيما الجانب الاوكراني اما فيما يتعلق
بالاوضاع هنا في الداخل لا اعلم غنوه ان
كانت الصوره واضحه خلفي فعليا هناك هدوء
تام في العاصمه موسكو لا يوجد هناك اي قلق
يعني بين ابناء الشعب الروسي في ظل هذه
الهجمات واود الاشاره الى تصريحات كان قد
صدرت في وقت سابق من قبل الناطق باسم
الخارجيه ماريا زخاربه التي اشارت الى ان
مثل هذه الخطوات لا يمكن الا ان تزيد
تلاحم ابناء الشعب الروسي ودعمهم للعمليه
العسكريه
انه حركه السير تبدو عاديه شكرا لك من
موسكرانيا دريدي وكذلك الشكر موصول لمراسل
الجزيره من اوديسا عامر لافي